d'où le monde sait squeeze entre
aujourd'hui pour une vidéo sur ce faux
culs monsieur qu'on a attendu pendant
tant de temps tous ensemble en jouant
sur un w 2 et on est aujourd'hui avec
les ifs l'oeil bonjour à tous au alors
donc voilà donc c'est encore un petit
nouveau de la libye pendant le temps les
api seront pourtant même temps et puis
et puis voilà donc fly tu nous fais ton
cri pierre vercheval alors pour cette
petite vidéo j'ai décidé de faire un
petit bois de survival donc sur la map
un père change donc cenap qu'on va
découvrir avec fait on n'a jamais fait
donc lui l'a carrément j'en ai joué un
mode survival c'est bien ça oui c'est ça
ben en fait je j'ai fait d'émules - mois
des modes sont bi mais jamais vraiment
de mode survival merlin exactement oh
[ __ ] atteint sa charge pas qu'est ce
que c'est que cette merde attend de
l'autre joueur
ben oui mais moi ça ne veut ça ne
cherche pas du tout alors peut-être que
c'est ça la prise et que d'un coup ça
avait tout à oui c'est bon ça commence à
charger j'ai eu peur des gens d'aso que
j'ai eu peur donc alors pourquoi donc au
niveau des vidéos d'art fra 3 donc là
j'en ai sorti trois d'un coup donc une
vidéo en gros mes impressions ce que je
pense du jeu une vidéo larmes un petit
mode survival avec fly parce que c'est
que par deux sinon dans les faits que
d'autres les i et ensuite tu auras un
mode domination c'est saint flour guerre
terrestre confiance avec un maximum de
monde de l'alizé ça sera le gros bordel
j'espère au moins qu'on gagnera ou ou en
blanc bon moi ça on fera ça pour le lol
exactement oh [ __ ] temps ou que c'est
joli bordel au chapitre voilà c'est mon
dicale ok alors comment je sens qu'on va
se faire détruire je connais pas du tout
j'avais beau coller au cul comme du
quart à je connais pas du tout la mab
lui je sais que faut ramasser les
modèles sûr
sauvé mes gains ok bon déjà je
m'approche quelque chose hop
bien sûr que c'est beaucoup plus si rue
cas où la haac est bon là l'adhésion
savoir c'est facile donc j'ai pas voulu
mettre la marque ont attesté à la paris
games week ce que ça sert à rien je
pense que c'est un rêve sans lesquels
tout le monde s'est jeté
c'était le pari voilà on avait le choix
entre paris nantes 9 je sais plus trop à
quel donc j'espère je vous invite à
regarder la vidéo de mes impressions du
jeu avant de regarder cette vidéo parce
que dangereux
on va parler à quelques manches je pense
dans cette vidéo de w3b voit là bas
aussi précisément que donne m dos mais
l'impression que je n'ai pas encore fait
à l'heure actuelle où je fais cette
vidéo ce qui était assez stressant 20
points mais bon j'ai fomine de faire le
montage et tout est en plus question que
vous êtes un joueur pc c'est que à
williston armand-frappier sursis ou sur
une touche pour que ça ça passe et tu es
là tu as l air plutôt bien ma plein
mesurer votre choix
pour démontrer qu'avec des endroits pour
se cacher au n 1 par contre j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé l'armé en juin au pire pour
des tags est en jeu c'est la doublette
hic c'est donc au début c'est assez
facile je pense qu'une second fait le
mode survival jusqu'à maintenant
vous remarquez on fait des on prend le
modèle de l'ailier on les laisse
tranquilles sans sévérité
c'est le manque du monde a donc qu'est
ce que je voulais dire ma foi j'ai du
mal avec mon temps règles de jeu il faut
que je m'exerce il faut les machettes un
cahier de devoirs pour s'exercer à
commenter en live
tu peux rigoler lol merci des coûts les
anti flag
voilà ton et a le truc qui m'a déçu du
jeu par conséquent double suicide on ne
sait pas de chaire immédiatement je
trouve ça assez dommage quand même
enfin je sais pas si tu as déjà vu fly
sa coach double souci tu peux pas
immédiatement tiré comme dans les trains
parfois j'oublie de passer
mr bah je n'oublie pas prochainement je
suis me fait penser je te sujet cantons
précités c'était marqué à droite j'ai
quoi chien nike l'a fait gaffe tu vas
romande en plus se faire [ __ ] en fait
j'avais même pas compris que tu appelles
un radar en haut à gauche si tu as
besoin de les jeter bien mais [ __ ] de
clem et mais c'est pas possible
alors là [ __ ] on aurait dit on aurait
dit les chiens chuck norris machin avait
le plein de trucs
le machin qui passe entre les balles et
tout enfin bon alors attendez faudrait
peut-être penser à une stratégie puisque
là on fait la mégane et tout a pas de
problème de chiens mère qui ne meurent
pas avec une balle je fais mienne ça me
facilite mais à ce qu'il faudrait c'est
qu'on pense avoir vite faire tous les
recoins de la map pour se planquer après
je pense faire parce que là c'est pas
correct faire des boîtes et met un gros
risque de bien se faire allumer plus
tard pacifique mais ça va être lolilol
ans comme gemalto annonce le jeu est
quand même très très bien optimisé 1
franchement je suis quand même
impressionné au niveau des graphismes on
sait à peu près la même chose même si
nous quand même un petit peu amélioré
les graphismes sont pas au niveau des
textures je trouve ça un peu plus pur et
ça fait plus réel hélas faute d'appuis
sur f5 voilà vous recommencez butin à
isis a fait les énerver là c'est qu'ils
regardent la vidéo qu'à chaque fois je
venais de passer alors et lui en
accrocheur s'assurer que les hélicos je
sais pas le championnat n'a jamais fais
toi c'est vrai que tu as à chaque jour 3
où j'oublie j'ai eu un groupe et toi
aussi je te bénéfique et bah du coup
comme j'ai apprise et comme je suis
l'autre de l'intrigué à temps comment de
gaz
ils sont
cela évite de faire tuer je répète 50 à
jouer online c'est beaucoup plus simple
la mode sur ma gauche alors qu'à paris
games week en avez jamais joué en live
devant elle quand je trouverai je dis ça
je dis rien mais bon alors là si tu veux
ça c'est une caisse paye pour htts & sb
des munitions la bassée à l'espèce
d'ariella c'est pour des killstreaks et
la bassée explosif et pour t'acheter un
gilet pare-balles et là d'un atout en
fait emballer a marre il ya un atout en
fait c'est quoi tu meurs ça te fera un
live tous dansent chantent un genre
ouais c'est plutôt bien bon moment alors
que tu as ça va très vite se compliquer
on va très vite se faire submerger et
j'ai encore biais d'ateliers sur ce
[ __ ] les 148 sont absents s'il te
plaît j'oublie tout le temps mon foie
gras 12 à 10 il m'en voulait à chaque
fois que je le faisais même quand tu
vois pas chérie tu mettais le gic
t'aimons prochaine fois tu passe passe
au fusil j'en ai ras le cul fans jk les
prochaines fois qu'il fasse le cas j'en
ai marre je te prends même année et je
joue tout seul était à bout le pot pas
mal
alors comment le gaz cette machine et
encore je pense elle a joué j'ai pu
jouer hier soir en modifiant est la
vieille astuce fallait modifier la date
de son de leur dis je au 8 novembre au
point je veux c'est quand même
franchement je m'attendais à ce qu'il
fallait
parce qu'ils fassent à ce qu'il faille
faire un truc plus important nouveau toi
tu t'es pas que j'ai découvert sa fin le
rookie a découvert sa tête était votée
dans tous les autres
pourtant on mange et on s'intéresse à
concentrer vraiment des lancements en
fait t'as dur pour moi je suis tellement
une blouse en tête que le plus de
chaleur je vide où les michel joye c'est
vrai que fly c'est un nouveau joueur pc
donc si les phases super fort c'est à
dire qu'un tel gars devront pas pardon
d'avoir coupé mais tu attends mais je
tourne en rond avec un rémy faisait
complètement quoi j'ai tourné en rond
autour duquel sommes tout de suite là
leur parfum pour d'anciennes messieurs
dames
ferranti f5 ben c'est vrai que c'est
c'est quand même assez bon
l'intelligence artificielle est meilleur
mais il reste quand même assez qu'on
nourrit reste quand même aussi tchité ça
faut bien dire appuyez sur 5,5 secondes
j'étais en train d'améliorer f5
après est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
déjà des glitchs franchement je suis
j'en sais rien est ce qu'il ya des
glyphes direction voilà voilà voilà
genre la hâte en berne la 1re semaine
sous un pont du mavi chantois c'est les
masses tôt soit une install matobo en
leur tirant dessus tu peux répéter une
tirelire dessus bonjour mon copain tu
vois mon copain donc voilà je crois que
ces deux chargeurs et leur jardin voilà
j'en reviens il est mort en tant que je
ne comprends pas et se situent les deux
chargeurs normand il est mort les échos
je suis blessé au bas du fait que toi tu
es mort ou à manger des moules un sujet
que je suis dessus
ok ok ça marche je change bonjour je
propose que encore peu à peu près dans
cette zone là comme ça c'est plutôt pas
mal par contre de faire péter cette
bagnole ça sera pas très long pour nous
donc penser toujours les gens à faire
péter les criques aux alentours de bouc
sinon elle a scellé mais qu'il fait
péter ben ça vous fait dans la tronche
et c'est fini appuyez sur f5 sifflé à
chaque fois je crois aussi un doublé
tout le temps ça doit être super chiant
à regarder mais bon alors qu'un camion
tu sais dans quel pays système aurait
fait gaffe falloir des kamikazes genre
quand tu as un émirat il aura une scène
fait voilà ça c'est fait ça c'est fait
il arrive format cela commence à avoir
ma faudrait peut-être et avait un petit
raté j'ai mon ami ou que c'est joli
l'explosion ouais foulera il est mort
est-ce que vous pensez que le modèle est
aussi bon line et qui remplace ne se
passe dedans ce colloque c'est la grande
question est comment ça j'ai
l'impression est ce que le modèle est
plus fort maintenant que l'espace perso
je pense qu elle pourra voir le modèle
donc je sois pas vous dire les gens d
personnellement j'en sais rien pu sur à
5.5 secondes
bon faudrait qu'on comme par ici ma foi
je tends genre silva et à ses
éventuelles modern warfare 3 je
m'attendais à un truc vraiment pitoyable
et au final il s'avère franchement bien
je sais pas si je pense que c'est
d'accord exprime bien ouais tout cela
wayne w 2.5
mais bon on est bien content d'avoir
passé ce quand même une nette
amélioration du mais ça va normalement
on est vraiment nui des mois mais
normalement je crois que quand un jeu
blanc marqué mais quand tu as un
adversaire
on revit plus tard survivra pas au bac
avait acheté un service te plaît arrête
tu vois là je veux bien centex je me
suis écrié c'est le cas c'est vachement
bien c'est super stratégique je suis sûr
que c'est presque plus stratégiques sur
un axe de mode ou n'est quand même pas
des débats comme ça des nuits attends je
vais juste comprendre là tout va bien
avec nationaux c'est d'autant plus que
bon dans un mode zombies normal voilà
les zombies 9e vers toi bon même si tu
en balançant leurs bras n'importe
comment il arrive à 40 meur nommant de
dégâts ils n'ont pas de flingues tire
pas loin alors que là ils font ça a
l'air sincère et on s'est fait baiser
parce que la ceni votre aise qu on
reprendra tous et on est on est allé
oui bon je te regarde
j'arrive déjà là pour vraiment je
restais de caller les trucs quoi on pas
qu'il bouffe je connais pas la touche
sur consoles boury les deux palaja pouey
ça marche le chien jeu de l'année autant
sur pc le temps que joël à tous je pense
qu'il me range à bouffer que sur la
scène ils ont leur foutu c'est le texte
qu'est ce que c'est chiant c'est
vraiment énervant et quand tu que cela à
l moi je fais avec la battue mais encore
là et un mot cna c'est bon d'accord elle
a aussi un truc qu'on a remarqué c'est
les couteaux quand tu code coller aux
mecs ça ne tue pas en fait je sais pas
pourquoi
en voici que ça bug ça fait un truc
genre comme ça bon genre la version que
la mecque et là ça va faire ça un truc
chelou comme ça bon j'exagère mais ça
prend ça et c'est vraiment chiant
alors que quand tu es loin c'est les
mains commando et salwa ça me tue direct
par un c'est un petit défaut à puis
appuyez sur ces pour commencer ou
attendant c'est moi qu'ils appuient sur
sept et j'appuie sur pied bon en fait
foi plus chacun sur cinq ans
alors effectivement bon bah écoutes je
ne savais pas de façon c'est la première
fois qu'un mode survival sorgi en plus
sur sept marathons l'a fait gaffe en
gros c'est un hélico qui largue un
mastodonte je vais de ce pas les truies
ou alors c'est un peu flou
je sais pas non regardez un machin qui
tombe break
tu voyais alma ce taux qui tombe et je
vais me planquer de foot après la mecque
ce sera bon de redmont ailleurs
commandes et la haye jay z ou paix toute
assez près d'alger cette affaire a même
dit il alors parce que là il n'est pas
bien mais mon projet et ses mains c'est
bon là il est bon il est bon comme en
commun comme un chat ni quand il a eu
beau tout chaud le que j'avais été
sympathique ils étaient sympathiques mon
portable vient de vivre est dans ma
poche gauche ça me stresse balcon c'est
pas une vidéo très fun vous l'aurez
remarqué comme toutes les vidéos doublé
3 qui sortit pour le moment ça c'est un
réflexe de liquider mais bon à chaque
fois mais a besoin qu'ils étaient pas il
ya de bons faith commenté ricky vont
arriver par contre je rage répondrai que
c'est bon n'empêche soleil
j'ai quand même je rage quand même très
souvent même sur ce je pense tu fais
remarquer ou les voilà un mois ou six
jours âge beaucoup plus que toi tu as tu
remarqué tout à l'heure j'ai eu un
tirage plaisir c'est très marrant
j'espère que la vie de quoi interpeler
tous ensemble ça sera bien comique sera
bien marc hovasse clôturage c'est quand
même très très marrant tu fais un espèce
de crime et franchement c'est évidemment
il fait un une crise dure là la bulle en
sait quelque chose
ça me fait bien jaser c'est un message
final à savoir les sourcils dans un
nombre assez critique j'ai entendu vous
êtes baissé à couvert à un vieux voilà
bon ben voilà ça c'est fait tu peux bien
bel et si tu veux mais fais attention
fait attention et son plein
ils ont fait non merde merde on va
crever qu'il faut que google était leur
éditeur dj
je peux pas mourir dans la lignée ils
sont pleins effets membres on perd tous
les bars maynard tu peux pas très bien
qui me change quoi voilà l ouest et
c'est bien ça le bus 1033 bon pour 20
ans féru l'écoutent c'était ce fut un
plaisir c'était assez nul bon je dois
l'avouer on a été très mauvais
maintenant on connait c'est pas la main
pour était vraiment des big band 3 non
même pas non non le mail de la belle
prend trop bas écouter jean j'espère que
tu vas tu rigoles vous aura plu en tout
cas je remets le menu des vidéos mw3
dans un instant c'est parti 3 des
revenus et puis marseille et un petit
revoir au plus que les gens échouent
baca derrière moi qui crie